do you have a view
on who you'd like to see as the next
prime minister
yeah i do it should be kirsten i should
i think whoever wins the tory leadership
contest
should call a general election so the
british public can have a choice to have
a fresh start all these candidates our
continuity boris johnson they supported
defended and have enabled him to be
prime minister for more than three years
and i think the british public should
have a say rather than just those who
are members of the tory party
well you know that's not going to happen
do you have a view of
which of the of those three
well well no i i think uh richie sunak
is the architect of what we've seen in
the last two three years in relation to
our economy
uh you know we know liz trust is a big
ally of uh boris johnson
i know less about penny penny morden uh
but you know
the reality is all three of them have
been big supporters defenders and
enablers of boris johnson what's
important though is until uh the new
lead is elected we should have a prime
minister doing his job and i think what
boris johnson should do is step aside uh
he can have further parties and you know
become tom cruise and allow dominic rob
to be the caretaker prime minister
because we need a full-time prime
minister and looking after the
well-being of our country rather than
somebody who's checked out
okay let's talk about the concerns of
the people who used to live in these
houses that we're looking at at the
moment or on a split screen
so we can see while we're still talking
to you mr khan uh
it's within your remit you're
responsible for the welfare of these
poor people what happens now
so yesterday was the busiest day for the
fire service in london since the second
world war on a normal
day the fire service receives roughly
speaking 350 calls on a busy day 500
calls yesterday they received more than
2 600 calls
more than a dozen simultaneous fires
requiring 30 engines like the one you're
at a couple requiring 15 some are
grinding 12 some requiring 10 and that's
why the fire service declared a major
incident i'm afraid the bad news is as
we can see from the images 41 properties
destroyed in london
16 fighters were injured some extent two
taken to hospital because of heat stress
it is really important though for us to
recognize uh that one of the
consequences of climate change and these
sorts of temperatures which lead to the
sort of fires you're seeing behind you
the challenge in london is we've got a
lot of grass uh you know a lot of green
spaces but a lot of it impinges on
properties and we've had rain for a long
period when the grass is incredibly dry
fires can start very quickly and spread
even faster because of wind and that
leads to properties being destroyed the
good news is
the fire service today
will be providing an excellent service
the first fire engine today will reach
you within six minutes six minutes
second engine within eight eight
yesterday it was taking 20 minutes
because of the pressure the fire service
was under
you said 41 properties destroyed sorry
can you just um tell me a little bit
more about that
yes a number of properties across london
destroyed some homes as we're seeing
some warehouses and other properties as
well and a major factor was in some of
these properties being destroyed was
their proximity to grass you know many
properties in london are next to grass
and it's similar to what you see in
california and in the south of france in
relation to fires next to densely
populated areas
so in this country the the main
fires of this scale we see is the
national parks or the moors which don't
impinge your property unfortunately in
london many of our properties are it's a
good thing
for the vast majority of time many of
our properties are next to green spaces
but one of the downsizes when you have
this exceptional weather this uh you
know red alert level four according to
the met office you know you have
situations where fires can start easily
and spread even faster
um
this area is not within the ules zone
new layers are very important to you of
course isn't it in trying to
tackle climate change um
is that something that you're going to
have to look at and spread that area
right even further
well there's one of the things that
really makes me angry in relation to
what we've seen in the last few days is
it takes what we've seen in the last few
days this extreme weather this heat wave
level 4 red alert
at the same time there's a leadership
contest to choose the next prime
minister and no one's talking about the
elephant in the room which is climate
change causing the sort of heat waves
where temperatures are exceeding 40
degrees we've got a situation where we
have heat waves every two or three years
rather than every 10 or 15 years and the
temperatures aren't mid-20s they're
approaching 40 degrees if not higher
leading to the fires we saw yesterday
and many excess
deaths what we should be doing is
dealing with the consequences of climate
change and air quality cleaning up the
air
less premature deaths less children with
stunted lungs less carbon emissions but
also dealing with the causes as well and
what we're doing in london is dealing
with the causes of climate change and
air quality by having policies that
reduce carbon emissions reduce nitrogen
dioxide reduce particulate matter like
cultural emission zone plant record
numbers of trees having water fountains
across our city cooling our homes
air-conditioned new trains but we need
support from the government as well
because we can't do it alone and the
only people that can really support us
to tackle climate change in terms of the
causes but also the consequences are the
government rather than us kicking the
can down the road we should be sprinting
to get to zero carbon
so you're saying the government's
failing on on climate change on their
climate policies so what are you
suggesting
a number of a number of things we can do
one of the biggest issues we face are
energy bills that's because we're
relying upon you know gas and oil from
you know russia or qatar or saudi arabia
why don't we use this crisis as an
opportunity to invest in wind and solar
so we're not reliant we have energy
security and it brings the bills down
one of the big challenges we face
post-brexit is what's the future of our
economy i think there should be
high-skilled well-paid jobs why don't we
be invested in people insulating
people's homes installing cooling
systems putting double glazing in that
will lead to energy efficiency less
carbon emissions but lower bills because
uh homes are more efficient uh district
heating pumps we should be you know be
be the people that are solving these
problems uh using the opportunity of a
crisis to create prosperity and wealth
rather than kicking the can down the
road
asking for a green pass rather than
dealing these big challenges you know a
lot of the problems we have today are a
direct consequence of climate change
excess death because of the heat wave
the sort of fires we saw yesterday
energy bills are escalating uh you know
people being in
jobs that aren't well paid lower skilled
jobs a lot of these problems can be
solved by tackling climate change
expediently
rather than you know rather than kicking
the can down the road
and what advice are you giving to the
people of greater london over
the next few days i mean it is getting
cooler now i i heard talk of barbecues
being banned certainly in parks i know
that when they have
hot days or used to when they had very
hot days in australia barbecues were
just banned no one could have one even
in their back garden
yeah look these are exceptional times
and because of uh the ease with which
grass is catching fire and the the speed
with which it spreads
we are advising people not to have
barbecues not to have barbecues in your
balcony
at parks nor in your private garden for
today these are exceptional times which
call for exceptional measures none of us
wants to be a party pooper but how would
you feel if you had a barbecue in your
back garden and uh some of the grass
which is like hay caught fire and it
spread uh damaged your property risked
your well-being and spread to your
neighbors our firefighters are working
incredibly hard they're they're they're
they're the heroes yesterday they need
some respite as well a very simple thing
we can do is just another day uh without
a barbecue and please also if you're
near water don't be tempted to jump in
whether it's the thames whether it's a
canal or whether it's you know other
forms of water over the last few days
across the country we've seen nine
people losing their lives in london
tragically a 14 year old child jumped
into the river near hampton uh his body
was recovered yesterday so let's try and
be sensible uh whilst we're going
through this heat wave to support public
services but to support each other as
well
um we must leave it there mr mayor thank
you for sparing your time for us this
morning much appreciated stay safe